unfortunately i think the judge and the
jurors are not getting due process
either because
with this the crowd mob mentality and
the ability for people to organize on
twitter and docs and like go to their
house that day and be like hey i'm not
in
you know louisiana but you are go get
this address in louisiana they're not
safe
sure but if you're like a spineless
coward like judge cahill
then you shouldn't be addressed well if
in reality if your choice is he's gonna
die or i'm gonna die
and that's just your job what are you
gonna choose
well if you're a coward you'll you'll
you'll let the innocent person suffer to
save your own skin
but if you're brave and principled you
will say i will stand my ground
so be it and then that's not to expect
from a civil servant
that's right oh absolutely it may be the
standard we should expect
right arguably but they'll just get
replaced but it's it's a lot to expect
it's a guy it's insane to expect that no
that's not a way to survive a society no
no no you can't expect the judges to
sacrifice themselves
if every single judge every time said
f you you will not terrorize me into
putting an innocent man in prison
we would not have this problem i don't
think so i think that they then they
would get destroyed
by who by what by the angry mob and then
the government would put
new obedient judges into the issue of
complacent
spineless and feckless leadership the
prosecutors who won't prosecute the
rioters
the police who grovel and lick the boots
of their democratic leadership that
sells them out
and you have you have a system where as
you mentioned prosecutors are like i'm
going to pass the buck i don't want to
be involved
grow a spine and go on tv and say this
is what happened if you've got a problem
with it i don't know to tell you it's
part of why
we have covert ops you don't want to
know who or you're not supposed to know
who the people spying on you are because
you'll go they'll go get executed so
you kind of i don't i don't necessarily
think we need like secret
judges and juries making these like
behind-the-scenes decisions but if there
was a way to protect their identities
uh that i think is the future of of
judiciary unite
america the public has a right to know i
do agree with that but
only to know that they're real people
you don't need to know their identity
their identities i disagree what if what
if what if the government starts putting
up juries of a bunch of uh tech
billionaires and you're like well
they're real people we know it's true
we don't know who they are and it's all
a bunch of billionaires or gang members
or whatever
you could maybe know you don't give the
government the power to do that
government needs to be transparent the
problem is
all of these politicians in minnesota
are sitting there thinking like
well i'm more important than anyone else
i don't care about my community or the
betterment of my children's future
i would rather sell everyone else out to
save my own skin
that's what they're saying well i think
they think it's a transient problem i
think they're thinking hey we got this
droid floyd trial going on now the
chauvin trial
let's just get through it we'll get
through it it'll be over if we can get
through it without the city incurring a
billion
dollars in property damage and a bunch
of other people getting killed
well that means we got to sacrifice one
cop maybe not give them perfect
due process of law well that's just
that's just the price we're gonna pay
we're not gonna
we're not gonna incur those billions of
dollars of property and that's even
before you get to their own
self-interest my job my career my safety
so they can frame it in their minds as
doing the greatest good for the greatest
number of people
and let's face it it's not like chauvin
fell off a building onto george floyd he
was actively using
force on george floyd and they may tell
themselves listen he took the job as a
cop this is one of the risks especially
in this political environment he could
have retired the year before
right and not been doing that and he has
that right no one was making him be a
cop
and that's why i say any one of these
cops in minnesota right now
the next time this happens kim potter i
don't i don't care
they can lock kim kim potter up here
what was it second degree medicine was
that 10 years
i'd have to check it's something in that
range 10 to 20 years she'll probably get
four or something because she's not no
criminal history
you know but there's a lot there's other
aggravating factors so once they decide
it's a crime they convict you on
anything well then you're a criminal
and then you committed the crime while
in police uniform wearing a badge and
that becomes an aggravating factor for
sentencing i mean that's what chauvin's
looking at now so
under under normal sentencing guidelines
with no priors he'd been looking at
about 10 years
which means he'd get out in like six
years but they filed what they call for
blakely
aggravating factors he was a cop wearing
a badge
in uniform in front of children uh part
of a group of people the other police
officers involved so he could be looking
at
way more time than time do you think
these officers
in minnesota would hesitate to arrest
you on a gun charge if you were
if you were constitutionally bearing uh
constitutionally expressing your right
to bear arms
not if it violated a minnesota statute
they'd arrest you in a heartbeat
on the spot yeah and so you have you
have these cops
that we you see the violence and the
destruction happening in these places
they also don't want law-abiding
citizens to have the ability to defend
themselves
now i understand the cops aren't the
ones who made the laws but being the
ones who enforce it at a time when the
city has been attacked
when buildings have been destroyed the
police department is under threat and
they
still work to support a system they know
is crooked
after everything that happened they
would still without hesitation take away
your right to defend yourself as a law
abiding citizen
and then after choosing to stand in a
burning building
while threatening my rights to
self-defense expect me to defend them
never going to happen kim potter can go
to prison for all i care
she chose this she knows what the
corrupt spineless politicians are doing
and i have no sympathy for anybody who
chooses to stand in a burning building
when i say get out and they don't
well a lot of them are getting out some
of them some of them
you know they may make different choices
but the fact is every cop knows that he
doesn't work for himself
he's not his own law enforcement agency
he works for a hierarchy of people above
him and ultimately he works for
politicians so
his police chief the guy at the top of
his department that is a political
position folks that's not a law
enforcement position just because he
wears a uniform and has a badge
he's not a cop anymore he's a politician
now
so ultimately the cops don't work for
themselves they work
for the politicians if they don't like
doing that then they can't keep the job
they shouldn't i mean after anything
that's happened my attitude is
for one if you're still going to stay in
these cities
where all these problems are happening
it's not just
happening in a vacuum it's not like all
of a sudden i'm standing alongside these
leftists being like yeah all cops are
bad no no i'm not saying that at all
what i'm saying is
we had we had a what what are we going
on now almost a year of riots
now before the before the election we
had
months of rioting we had a political
system supporting the rioters we had a
kamala harris soliciting funds for the
rioters joe biden's staff
donating funds for the rioters absolute
support
for the cast and destruction and an
establishment media saying peaceful
protests while their fire raging behind
them
and i said okay let's defend you know uh
our police officers not all perfect
should be pleasing accountability i
respect all that
the trial i get let's have a fair trial
let's have some police reform
the argument didn't work the people
decided that they should vote for those
who supported the rioters
we are seeing an escalation of or should
say a collapse of our justice system
and there are still to this day cop
saying i'm going to sit here in a
burning building okay
well when the fire started and we all
tried putting it out and it didn't work
and the fire took over the building
then i said time to get out of the
building guys you said no i'm cool i'll
stay i said all right
so when the building comes down on you
don't expect me to get sick it's a real
dilemma right because what what choices
do the cops have they can stay or they
can go
if they go they're not cops anymore so
they're not helping us there right
they're not they're not good
why not what how is it not helping if
they're going to stay in a city
that is if they're supporting corrupt
politicians
and corrupt judges they're saying if
they leave the job they're not fighting
crime anymore
right they're not serving that societal
purpose anymore because they're not no
longer police they've they've left the
job
if they stay maybe they feel they can
still most of the time
do something for crime but yes
admittedly by staying
you're working for the body politic that
gives you that job
and you've got uh uh
resident residents of these cities who
don't want to do anything to support the
police to express their support for
police well apparently quite the
opposite
why why are people martial they're
voting for the prosecutors and they're
voting for the lawyers they're voting
for
you know their support supporting the
anti-police initiative
so then what gives these cops the right
to reject the will of the people and
think they can stay here and go into
these neighborhoods where they don't
or they aren't wanted well they can
because the politicians say you can go
and just be be don't be surprised when
uh
we serve you up in the next witch trial
so these cops
and the good ones won't stay i mean any
that can get out with any
any fraction of whatever they've earned
in terms of a pension
uh they're going to leave uh they leave
the profession entirely or they'll join
the state police or the sheriff's
department or
move to some other jurisdiction entirely
uh they'll get out while they can you
know when you look at the the all the
they had a lot of police testify for the
state during the chauvin trial
uh none of them were street cops they
were from the academy
they were trainers uh or they were uh an
80 year old or 70 year old homicide
detective who doesn't do street work
anymore he shows up after everything's
done and talks to witnesses
or they had a sergeant who again shows
up after the fact
if there's been certain use of force
threshold reached you have to call your
sergeant so he can write a report
but none of them are making hands-on
arrests they didn't call any street cops
you know who called the street cop
the defense called the street cop right
the guy who was involved in the first
george floyd intentional ingestion of
drugs
related arrest uh he and he was there to
attest to the body cam video
and he was like yeah no this is what
george floyd does
this is should have been entirely
expected because this is
the same behavior that i experienced and
he stepped right through it
and there's a reason the prosecution
didn't call any actual street cops
because they didn't want street cop
testimony
in that trial what they got were the
cops who were still there
who weren't on the street because
they're in the academy they're in
headquarters during senior homicide
positions
where they're not actually expected to
go hands-on with anybody
i look at what's going on in many of
these cities and just think
the cops at this point who are staying
are propping up a corrupt system
and they're allowing it to persist and
it's more than that
i for a while operate under the
assumption that regular people wanted
police
and i noticed a lot of conservatives do
this where it's like clearly people want
crime to be stopped
but then i saw the mikaya bryant thing
when
and i saw that incident in new york city
where the woman got shot in the head and
i realized something
they're telling us in no uncertain terms
and we're just not getting it through
our thick skulls
when a woman shoots another one ahead in
new york it's not news no one cares
crump doesn't show up there's no
lawsuits no lawyers no one complains
cops don't got to do anything cops
aren't at risk cops are fine the people
want to live that way
when micaiah bryant is fighting and she
pulls a knife and tries to stab someone
the cop intervenes
immediately in that body camera footage
i was amazed to see
the people turned the cops out yelling
what did you do why did you do that it's
like
didn't you just watch this lady wind up
with the knife
and then i thought to myself it's clear
they're not lying
they're literally saying let us have
neighborhoods riddled with violence and
crime we want that
we don't want your you to intervene in
fact
there was there was one instant uh
instance recently where i think someone
someone had their kid killed
i can't know what the story was the guys
refusing to talk to the cops about it at
all
and he said we do not want cops coming
in our neighborhood period
and i'm like then why are cops still
doing it why is anyone demanding
they should no the cops should leave
because the people have asked them to
right that's simple and of course every
cop knows now that if he does go hand on
with a suspect
the first thing that's going to happen
is all the bystanders are going to come
to the immediate conclusion that his use
of force was inappropriate
unlawful and those are exactly the kinds
of witnesses that were brought up in the
chauvin trial
by the way they mostly testified about
their feelings
about what happened which should not be
relevant in a criminal prosecution
that frankly they should not have been
permitted to say those words when they
said those words
it should have been objected to by the
defense i wondered why the defense
didn't object at the time
sometimes there's a broader strategy
that pays off later where you don't want
to be objecting even when you have the
privilege
unfortunately i never saw the payback
appear later during the trial so i'm not
sure what the defense counsel was there
for
they're supposed to testify about facts
their observations of what happened not
their feelings
about what happened we had witness after
witness after
witness literally gasp and cry and
tear on the witness stand that alone
should be grounds for a reversal of this
conviction
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time